[Music]
found alive news submitted by marina
Medina rescuers face a massive challenge
to save 12 young boys trapped in a cave
in Thailand [ __ ] I didn't hear about
this I don't know what's so they just
got 12 I just saw the thumbnail I just
saw the like my mom watches the news and
I just saw her and I was like that's
wild and I'm also confused because I was
watching part of that and did they send
Thai Navy SEALs or American Navy SEALs
oh it's a lot of countries right now
working together to get these kids that
are still in there oh wow why did they
go in there maybe not by the time this
video is supposed to maybe be happily
there yeah hopefully yeah I feel like
they said like like 12 like they should
have said one dude as a test for that
cave like make sure it was safe not like
go all in together there's 12 of them
dude yeah
12 kids in the coach those 13 people and
a [ __ ] coach yeah that Coach is not
doing the job the trapped in the game is
it going they came to explore know you
want to know why do I picture like the
Thai Navy SEALs being like these really
hot lady boys in [ __ ] bikinis and
stuff with machine guns and they all
know how to do Muay Thai and they have
like ropes on their hands with [ __ ]
glass on their on their [ __ ] fetish
for a Thai lady would you picture that
at all I don't even have a fetish I'm
just saying I really 10-inch didn't
events and I redo how many days have
they been in there do you know I only
like it when they have sex with women
wait who has sex with women
the Thai Navy SEALs like the Thai Navy
SEALs
alright so on Saturday June 23rd these
these twelve boys and their coach went
into this cave and so there are
conflicting reports one like some people
say that they went in for a picnic other
people say that they went in in a cave
that's some stupid-ass place to have a
picnic we're starting this journey
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't be a great place to have a
picnic and they can't hear you can still
put a blanket down you can still have a
basket of food you just canvas dark I
can't eat my sandwich in the dark
bad [ __ ] [ __ ] fish with no eyes and
[ __ ] better clearance [ __ ] like the cave
in the cave pools yeah so this is after
soccer practice and oh yeah and then the
other reports are saying that it might
have been part of initiate part of an
initiation slash fun thing to make it
inside the cave write their names on the
walls and then leave oh that sounds a
graffiti but did something happen where
like the rocks came down and block their
rain started happening like they had
this crazy rain so then they got trapped
in the cave and the water levels rose
and then so they didn't know where the
exit was obviously flooded er yeah flash
[ __ ] what else is in that cave all right
that be so stupid it's like they width
it the only way to go in is sideways and
after they went in there trying to leave
and they forgot that you gotta go to the
site [ __ ] yeah anyway so when they were
in there they couldn't hear the rain so
they didn't know like how far deep
inside the cave they went until it was
too late
and then so finally officials found
biggest boys after 10 days of them being
in there
Oh 10 days most of their rescue oh my no
they they were found what is that what
does that mean oh they're alive like
they can hear him knocking through the
walls no nobody knew they were in there
that's what you say no
I'm guessing no I want to guess tell me
there was a [ __ ] drawer drone that
like went in there and then they meet I
told you [ __ ] the clear you guys
laughs the [ __ ] invisible fish you
never seen that [ __ ] all you see is
funny I laughed at you but that's the
primary food source obviously no it's
called like a ghost fish or some [ __ ]
it's called like a ghost invisible fish
and if I were starving and it's just a
[ __ ] spine okay it's clear
no but the name of it is like the ghost
fish or some clothes I mean that thing
with the no that's a deep-water fish
okay no angular doing all right I'm
gonna show you guys a video clip of when
these British expert divers found these
kids so these two divers found them this
is kind of insensitive but like why does
the whole world care about these twelve
kids because it's uniting the world I
don't know just like why I'll be like
wise Navy SEALs and like British divers
and like awesome kids are the future
Navy SEALs therefore well who are they
that are protect what do they do
what's the British fools doing over
there oh she's gonna tell you you're
helping oh they were help those guys are
looking for any action they can find to
help that's why the what is the hole
because everyone goes to Thailand on
vacation to watch kickboxing and [ __ ]
hookers so that's why there's a lot
British dudes Devon sent it they're
already in town and when they heard the
news they're like holy [ __ ] we got to do
something we got a alright stop and then
they push the girl off and they [ __ ]
run on I put the wet suit on and then
they went to dive I think wouldn't get
back to the hotel after being stranded
here for like three weeks or whatever
they still have to pay like the maximum
amount for having all their [ __ ] in the
hotel for that long
how that's your worry like you people
are like oh I don't care if you're
talking a cave like you to like a lad
you're safe but it'll be ten days two
hundred got nothing to me man
we clean the room we're tall days
straight I don't want a business here
but I would great [ __ ] question right
when they were visiting these kids
aren't I kids or they are oh they are
types they don't even know what in check
into a hotel it's very weird they could
have been from another town let me show
you this video they're on a soccer trip
here we go sorry I thought cuz American
Helton was helping so well is that when
they got rescued why they're just taking
videos of these guys they should help
them do I hope they brought granola bar
be starving I told you those [ __ ]
water and okay no you did it yeah I mean
glad that nobody died and they finally
found it I know and they found everyone
to it like everyone's okay I met you
because they don't have diver gear and
[ __ ] they don't know how to get back out
all right Daisy what if they're just
trying to play the ultimate game of hide
and seek and then we [ __ ] it all up
no they were with no food or water or
shoes like I said the ultimate
hide-and-seek these are the Altima don't
give a [ __ ] about food and water tight
and see so they left their backpacks and
their shoes outside the cave because I
don't know why agent without food or
anything this whole time they grew up
now they're these men right the question
I still have
yeah what the [ __ ] is happening Oh so
they've gotten a lot of machines to try
to pump the water out so the reason why
they can't easily just swim out of there
is because it's like about a three mile
stretch from the edge yeah
they were super dangerous like to dive
in that like these bring a [ __ ]
bushel of like Thai curry to them how
come you can't just how come you can't
pick up an 80 pound kid you can carry 80
pound bag because it's really really
they're like third point parts where
it's like super narrow I don't know how
they're taking food it might have
limited to like they're saying like it's
too narrow for scuba tanks they have
photographers winning that [ __ ]
this is literally the worst place a
sandwich or a sandal I don't even know
how
oh but that's not the entrance it's like
we're gonna have a picnic it's like can
we just sit down here is like we're
gonna go three miles there which two now
a scuba tank
okay now can we set up here this
two-mile radius no no one more mile
longer guess we got a mile to go
everyone starting when the rain comes in
so they are trying to fight against time
because over the weekend there's gonna
be like some monsoons so the water
levels cook well so as of right now
they're just trying to get these kids oh
man strong again because they're very
very weak after telling so they can't
wait they can't move
they're super weak they have four like
there's like four people that are there
with them like three other Navy Navy
SEALs and also they dove under and then
they're like their wisdom laid out the
coach isn't easy the only adult his eyes
should be [ __ ] fired
but how idea he's the coach the kids are
suggesting like God yeah wonder was a
kid then he got suckered in he up your
brain so he's like oh if I get out of
this don't I'm only going to the cave
seven times a year it was creepy too
because they went in there with only one
flashlight and the better day
[ __ ] they think Oh
I wouldn't go that deep into a cave like
that [ __ ] deep that I don't even know
where to go yeah one flashlight no shoes
you can't see even 12 kids flashing one
flashlight on them in those 10 days they
were just in complete darkness they had
to figure out like what to eat or
whatever yeah I've been trying to find
out like how do they know they're I'm
also curious how do you found them - I
don't know I mean they were looking for
the last 10 days as much as we
criticises coach he packed a [ __ ] of a
lunch that's probably what they survived
no but you know what they probably got
Pitt like after they pi enjoyed an
actual picnic they're done with all
their food and they're like oh [ __ ]
they've I enjoyed a picnic first you
know what I mean like they didn't think
they're gonna get stuck well now imagine
like you're there with your middle
school friends or whatever and you guys
are like have to piss and [ __ ] around
each other now just like live in your
piss and [ __ ]
ten days wait 10 days what no that's it
was it's been like I think four days now
since they've been found so it's been 14
days Oh
birthday song inside the cave yeah I
mean that's half a month you know that's
crazy they can pump out the water
quickly enough so they the kids could
just walk out of there but plan B is to
get these kids because none of them know
how to swim oh my I mean at least
they're gonna survive because you know
they got people there attending to them
I hope so can we get a video message
from Timothy DeLaGhetto over there some
kind of encouragement yeah yo Tim if
you're watching this we need you right
now ro the only Tiger you're the last
hope dude I mean he I if it's anyone
it's gonna be him cuz he could go in
that cave I would love to see Tim knock
it out - he's like I hope you guys make
it and don't forget to eat the booty
damn it's not during this Tim's gonna go
in there to play improv games with them
and [ __ ] like a koala now here we go
he's got a battle rap
[Music]
[Music]